before healthcare.gov even launched  testing showed big problems crashing  with just 11 hundred users during stress  tests on day one only six people  enrolled by day to 248 tens of thousands  idling in a virtual waiting room the  White House noted 8.6 million people  visited in the first three days but  signing up was another story the White  House announced an emergency text search  led by incoming chief economic advisor  Jeff Zients and fired its main  contractor and promoted another by the  end of the month only 106,000 had signed  up well behind the government's target  of 800,000 and most of those signups  came from state-run exchanges but by the  end of the year obamacare enrollment  rallied through December 2.1 million  people enrolled 1.6 million in December  alone through February that number  jumped to 4.2 million leading into the  final March push to sign up last week  the President on a conference call  announced a milestone enrollment had hit  six million